anyway Riya I'm a deceiver 23 I love it
great but the thing is is this is that
you know the slub King Papa Papa Papa
right happen okay the captain on the
captain okay all right princess Cory I'm
a lot of things okay and I'm not I'm
ashamed a lot of it but yes I've been in
many wars well this was the funny thing
I did that intro I get off and I'm like
okay hopefully he won't be mad you know
he didn't see that it was fake and I go
over and our egos but you don't have to
go that far but you also at that time
and don't get mad but I'm gonna bring it
up okay I know this is your podcast but
you told Tommy if he made me a regular
you would never come in there again yeah
oh yeah know that I ever tell Tommy if
you [ __ ] know I want to apologize too
for that and that was like low that was
probably of all the things you guys
mentioned the lowest oh yes well that
was a direct hit where I was like cuz
Tommy told me because he never not told
anybody and now that you said that I
feel shame I do I'm not doing the same
walk I'm absorbing I'm observing the
shame and we already went through I am
doing it again though let me shed it
therapy okay
I'm ashamed of that I'm not justifying
two sleepers out there listening all
right I'm not justifying it you know
anything but it was out of survival and
about what I did it was so [ __ ] up and
I'm really shame I was kidding about
this all right it's not about survival
what I've been in a battle i flip-flops
at night
you [ __ ] your white [ __ ] laughs right
now it's really just [ __ ] grading on
me right now yes I think I did I
remembered you telling Tommy that here's
another thing that you did just a story
if we're gonna do it so just get it out
there right so one day I'm at the Comedy
Store and a couple of comics up to me
and goes is telling every she's telling
everyone upstairs that you're gay like
as a joke no full-blown you sucked off
Andy Dick in the bathroom timeout here's
the deal yeah Ashley Hamilton it was
actually handled yeah yeah new guy kind
of gullible whatever his father his
father's an actor George hamil yes ah
yeah yeah yeah great guy great guy he's
trying him and I started stand-up
together but I have a long history with
comics so we're sitting there with Brian
Holtzman yeah and this guy so we have
Brian Holtzman we're sitting there and
Ashley's like well my favorite comics
Bobby Lee or something like that we mean
Brian immediately go into look at each
other has no idea of our history
he's not gay Ashley says that yeah oh
yeah because that was a rumor
why did somebody brought to me lied that
they caught you in the main okay
stopstopstop shamed yeah yeah I'm
telling you what the rumor is yeah I I
didn't start if I tell you this right
now because he started his own room to
do that a lot I'm gonna tell you what it
is okay is one night years ago Andy Dick
was at The Comedy Store yeah it was Andy
Dick okay and he was blitzed out of his
mind and this is when news radio so he
was like do we have a party it was a
party that night yeah I remember
cleaning up like a minute why it was
wild that yeah I went to the bathroom as
a doorman I had the Comedy Store shirt
he follows me in there right and he
pulls his dick out mm-hmm and I walked
out of the [ __ ] bathroom that's all
that happened okay but other door men
III know I know they saw me walk in
there with them but let me say this
right now I have I have I suck dick
before
yes yeah but I don't know any I'll tell
you right now I just never ate I never
did it at The Comedy Store I did it as a
younger man and I thank you sweetie
thank you so much only reason is you've
always been pretty transparent about all
your previous dick sucking that wasn't
it why would denies sucking a dick of a
celebrity so all right so that soii I
ratted you out right - Tommy you try to
spread the rumor that with him to the
store he came to the comedy store Ashley
Hamilton looks at me right in my face he
calls you know if he look him okay and
literally literally the I had such oh
yeah I was like just polyps No